Nvidia selling lies and reviewers
shouldn't be afraid to mince words about
it that is precisely what the RTX 570 is
it is marketed on the back of Lies with
the Blackwell family RTX
570 490 performance at
549 impossible without the Four Tops
four ter Ops of AI 5070 490 performance
$549 that's right and says that AI can
make a 570 which has 12 GB of vram equal
490 which has 24 here's an Nvidia
compliance comparison of the RTX 570
with MFG versus the 490 without any
frame generation at all just stock these
are abusive settings stressing both
cards heavily but Nvidia said 490
performance and we're not even close the
5070 spiky behavior is exceeding 200
milliseconds in this like for like
comparison except it has MFG the 490
isn't perfect but without any frame
generation at all it's hitting at worst
50 to 60 milliseconds an average of
closer to 26 here's what that problem
actually looks like using nvidia's own
frame view tool we get a glimpse into
another problem which is latency the PC
latency on the 490 was around 51
milliseconds during this like for like
comparison 51 is a lot better than what
we saw in the 5070 with MFG 4X after 5
minutes of being in the game that was
500 to 720 milliseconds now to be fair
if you only played cyberpunk with these
settings for about 15 to 20 seconds at a
time things look a lot better the 5070
is getting absolutely clobbered for vram
which is just 12 GB to the 490s 24 to
call these the same is an absolute
Flatout lie these cards are not the same
in situations where the card runs out of
vram in particular it could never dream
to be a 4090 it is simply impossible
here's a quick chart showing passes one
through three of the 5070 as it gets
progressively worse with each Benchmark
pass as the frame buffer fills the 490
meanwhile maintains its performance the
entire time so did we pick an absolutely
ridiculous comparison to make with
extremely abusive settings that you
might not use on a
5070 yes yes we did is it
compliant also yes so Nidia look look
it's just us right now stop lying just
shut up even if we pretend a 5070 with
MFG is equal to a 4090 in a Serial
that's maybe not vram constrained it's
still not like for like because the
images themselves are not the same when
you turn it on it's like Clive here from
Final Fantasy or whatever his name is
has six feet I mean if that's what
Jensen's into then to each their own I
guess wait for
it wait for it and the memes will
continue until the marketing improves
now Nvidia does know that Gamers at one
point mattered for its brand that's why
there's so many amazing things that are
happening we used GeForce to enable
artificial intelligence and now
artificial intelligence is
revolutionizing GeForce you bring it
home to your
$10,000 PC
entertainment Command Center isn't that
right sometimes corpos be can be a
little wordy and indirect so let me just
let me just translate that for
you [__] you that's what they said
Nvidia said [__] you Gamers before that
this video is brought to you by the
montac hyperlow series of liquid coolers
the montac hyperflow aims to compete
with other affordable liquid coolers by
fighting on price to Performance in our
testing cooler performance was
comparable to others in its class the
argb hyperflow has an illuminated pump
block with RGB LED fans that have
quality rubber bumpers for vibration
damping the cooler has a 6-year warranty
and supports all modern Intel and AMD
sockets and you can learn more at the
link in the description below and video
could have launched its RTX 570 today to
lukewarm reviews and mediocrity but
instead it went all in it decided to get
on stage and lie about what the 5070
could be making every possible unforced
error in the launch cycle of the 50
Series all of this was avoidable but
this 5070 and 490 comparison in
particular was a totally unnecessary fun
Umble we could have just read all the
numbers off and called it a day and said
mediocre lukewarm wait for the 970 XT
and non XT reviews tomorrow but instead
we get to start with talking about line
and marketing and then we can read all
the numbers do you see how this works
Nvidia and now we're going to get into
the rest of the review as normal the RTX
57 is supposed to have an MSRP of $550
now there's an elephant in this room and
we all know how Jensen Juan feels about
about elephants four
elephants one GPU it's hard to say what
it'll actually be available for for
Street pricing but basing off of only
MSRP that makes this card $50 higher
than the MSRP of the RTX 370 had its
launched in 2020 and $50 cheaper than
the RTX 470 is launch MSRP of $600 this
kind of looks like a patterned stutter
stepping where Nvidia will go a little
too high overshoot on a generation the
next one it comes down and then it
creeps back up a little bit higher and
so you end up with this gradual
stuttered step of price increases we saw
this from 10 to 20 20 to 30 and 30 to 40
and now we're seeing it again but the
RTX 570 GPU has an advertised 6,144 Cuda
cor a 192bit bus and 12 gigb of tdd R7
memory it might even have all the RS the
570 TI has an MSRP at 700 $50 and
Carries 16 GB of gddr 7 memory on a
256bit bus so there's more bandwidth
there's little bit more capacity and
there's an increase to 8,960 Cuda cor
and it has the surprise mechanic of
maybe not having all of the RS clocks on
the 5070 are advertised at 2.51 GHz
boost now it felt like the world didn't
have enough absurdity in it today so we
went and looked at new EG here's how it
breaks down there are five MSRP models
for the 5070 TI on new EG right now
which is just enough to technically
claim that MSRP exists the rest of them
are all higher often $900 and over board
Partners have now directly repriced
their cards with video cards noticing
that MSI had eliminated all of its $750
570 TI cards just before the 570
launches interestingly though as we
write this review following the video
cards News Post MSI has now reintroduced
two $750 models dropping from 820 and
840 to 750 Nvidia has historically
applied pressure to Partners to make
MSRP units available so it wouldn't
surprise us if the video card story
triggered a reaction to keep two models
available they can also achieve this
with rebates anyway as for things
available right now as in you can
actually buy it we found the RX 7800 XT
pulse for $530
and that's it that is all we found when
we sorted new EG from $450 to $650 for
in stock and sold first party by Newegg
meaning no third parties no unavailable
Models All We Got were a bunch of
refurbished units and the 7800 XT pulse
so it really is crazy right now we'll
talk with that a little more in the next
two reviews and the conclusion of this
one we're going to get into the
benchmarks though uh this review
contains most of the games that we
Benchmark we've reintroduced some of the
ones that we didn't show the last couple
reviews because we're prepping for the
970 970 XT so we need that full picture
Suite to see how the cards behave in
different types of games we currently
have around 50 to 60 gpus or so tested
for this lineup with this bench in the
last uh two months or so now and so
because of that it's too many cards and
uh the charts you won't be able to read
them on the screen so we have to remove
some stuff and so here's what we went
through and did we've added the 7900 GRE
we won't be spending time talking about
it today because it'll be replaced
tomorrow and will likely be a key
comparison tomorrow for the 9070 series
but it's on the charts we're removing
either the 480 or the super in every
chart but keeping the other will favor
the super where we have data for it
that's because these gpus are within 1
to 3% of each other and it's not worth
the chart space to have two versions of
the same card we're also removing the
2080 TI 2080 super and 2080 most of
these results are already available in
our previous charts for the 570 TI
review those are directly comparable to
these you can pull them both up if you
want to access that data we're removing
the 80 with the missing DRS you can find
that in a standalone video also directly
comparable and of course we're removing
the 970 and the XT because we can't show
that data until tomorrow though we can
show the footage of it but as for the
data can't show it yet not that we've
looked at it or know where the 970 or
970 XT land and certainly we wouldn't
reference it in vague ambiguous ways at
all anywhere in the really dense charts
section uh and you're just going to have
to check back and there's there's not
going to be any hints let's get into it
Final Fantasy 14 Dawn Trail up first for
traditional raster title at 4K without
any [__] to artificially inflate the
numbers this game is actually playable
on most Modern Hardware at this
resolution the way it's supposed to be
the RTX 570 ran at 78 FPS average
Landing it right between the 4070 TI and
the 470 TI super maybe we should call it
the 4070 TI V3 instead the 5070 TI
outperforms the brand new RTX 4070 TI V3
Blackwell Edition by 25% here the 4070
TI super is ahead by 11% and the 7900 XT
by 6% going by name only and ignoring
the fact that you're getting less for
more these days from Nvidia the
generational lead over the 470 is 30% or
48% over the 370 118% over the 2070 and
244 over the Pascal 1070 unfortunately
for NVIDIA the 5070 is not better than
the 490 but if we were to be
artificially intelligent and actually
intellectually dishonest it might be the
970s will be on this chart tomorrow at
1440p the RTX 570 TI's lead over the 570
is reduced to 22% from 25% at 4K the 570
is also reduced at its advantage over
the 4070 TI now just 1% from around 6%
at 4K from 150 fps to 172 FPS we now
have three gpus from Nvidia that is if
you want to make Nvidia look as
ridiculous as possible you could
maximize the size of the clown car by
drawing a box from the 480 super at 202
fps to the 470 f at 117 FPS the result
is seven modern Nvidia gpus spanning an
85 FPS range all fresh from clown School
divided evenly that would be one GPU for
every 12 FPS in this situation though
four of them land within a 36 FPS range
the 5070 TI 4070 TI super 5070 and 4070
TI mean you can dial it in to the
individual decimals if you were so picky
about your performance the 700 XT lands
in the middle of all of these and has a
12% lead over the RTX 570 assuming all
the robs are present on the 5070 and the
5070 is again not better than the 490
RTX 570 490 performance are you guys
with me hi am I alone remarkably we
still have okay scaling at 1080p for
most of these gpus the fact that the
9800 x2d allows the 590 and the 490 to
still have a slight Gap at 1080p really
speaks volumes to how actually exciting
amd's 9800 X3 he is anyway back to the
flunky problem child which is gpus just
in their entirety the 5070 ran this
workload at 225 FPS average and fell
below the 470 ti no wonder Nvidia wants
everyone using MFG the 490 predictably
outperformed the 55070 massively it's a
67% Gap here the 700 XT now has a
reduced lead of 9% black myth who call
at 4K and rasterized had the 55070 at 40
FPS average giving the 570 TI a 27% lead
the 55070 really struggled in this one
and ended up tied with the 4070 TI and
to its benefit the 7800 XT we'll be
curious to see how the 970 does in this
one surely we don't already know as
we're writing this and definitely
haven't looked at the results and in no
way would we ever encourage you to just
wait and see what the results are
tomorrow if we knew but we don't and so
we will still encourage you to do that
if we were to randomly multiply the
frames then the 5070 would be better
than the 490 until you randomly multiply
the 490 with lossless scaling Jenson
claim is like a schoolyard argument the
570 is infinity times
better wait for
it wait for it at 1440p we reintroduced
other 70 class cards of the past the
5070 Fe ran out 72 FPS average with
frame time pacing unremarkable meaning
fine the 570 is tied with a 470 TI and
700 XT generationally by name only the
570 improves on the 470 by 22% the 370
by 58% and the 2070 non super by 137%
the 570 TI leads the 570 by 21% here
let's go faster through these the 1080p
result for Blackmouth has the 55070 down
at 98 FPS average allowing the 4070 TI a
gain to a 2% lead the 5070 TI is ahead
by 17.6% here assuming all of the RS are
present against the prior cards
containing 70 naming the 570 is ahead of
the 470 by 18% the 370s 63 FPS average
by 56% and the 2070s 43 FPS by 12 6%
Starfield at 4K is up now the 55070 ran
at 54 FPS average here giving the 4070
TI 59 FPS average a 9% lead it'd be
interesting if amd's 970 performed
similarly to the 700xt here since the
hellhound is 20% ahead of the 570 we'll
find out tomorrow again we definitely
haven't already looked at the data the
5070 TI has a larger lead over the 570
in this test than the last 1080p
Benchmark running a 68 FPS average for a
27% advantage over the 570 Fe
performance of the 570 over the 270 22
FPS is about 145% ahead 1440p
significantly reduces the 570 TI's
uplift over the 570 bringing it down to
22% from the prior 27% the 700 XT which
is an important comparison in this test
for reasons that might be comparable to
other cards coming out runs at 98 FPS
average with comparable lows to its
neighbors that has it 18% ahead of the
RTX 570 is 83 FPS average as for the 470
the 570 leads by a pol Tre 10.6% then
48% over the 370s 56 FPS at 1080p the
570s 104 FPS average planted at between
the 470 and 470 TI again with an
unimpressive 9% Improvement on the 470
the Gap shrinks as the resolution
decreases in this game the 5070 TI is
now ahead by only 19% down from 27% at
4K asra AMD it's rx700 XT is 15% ahead
here down slightly from the 1440p
advantage Dragon Dogma 2 at 4K is next
this game is relatively heavy on the GPU
in our test area but is unique for its
ability to also produce a heavy CPU load
in cities the RTX 570 ran at 56 FPS
average here and had good frame time
pacing represented in the lows but then
again so did everything around it so
it's proportional the 570 very slightly
leads the 470 TI as for the 490 we're
still somehow not matching the 490 which
is up at 98 FPS we must have mistyped
the equals 570 Time 4 formula that
Jensen prescribed for reviewers
impossible without the Four Tops four
ter Ops of AI the 5070 TI leads the 5070
by a much larger 31% of this Benchmark
producing one of the most notable jumps
yet the 39 DTI ran at 64 FPS for a 14%
lead over the 570 which might seem
totally nonse and unrelated but it isn't
you'll find out why soon anyway the 700
XT held a 61 FPS average in this one and
the XTX was just past the 570 TI Dragon
Dogma 2 at 1440p has the 5070 basically
tied with the 470 TI again the 700 XT is
104 FPS average is just a 9% lead here
with the 470 TI super a slight step
above that the 5070 TI has a 25% lead
over the 570 here posting one of its
better 1440p comparative results somehow
and we don't know how this happened the
RTX 490 just seems to be better than the
570 that's again it's so weird that just
must be something wrong maybe we should
run Nvidia multifraction generation to
divide the 490 down to a 570 with kind
of performance I'm going to hire AI next
time at 1080p the 5070 is 126 FPS
average has it just behind the 4070 TI
the 700xt leads by only 7% here with the
570 TI knocked down to a 21% lead from
25% at 1440p the 57 TI's 151 FPS average
is also about the same as the 700 XTX
which has its own slight Advantage as
for the 490 well hours really must be
broken because again it's just not
making the 570 look good enough I wonder
if this can play
prices only Gamers know that cyber Punk
Phantom Liberty is up now we have a more
limited data set with this because we
updated the game recently and we've been
working on rerunning everything at 4K
the 570 ran at 41 FPS average that put
it 6% ahead of the 470 TI and 144% ahead
of the 270 or 68% ahead of the 24 FPS
result of the 3070 as for the 5070 TI
its 50 FPS average gives it a 22% lead
here with the 7800 XTX ahead of that at
57 FPS average the 7800 XT has
noteworthy 13% lead over the 570 here at
1440p the 5070 ran at 89 FPS average and
had lows at 75 FPS 1% and 71 FPS 0.1%
the 570 TI at 108 FPS average is about
21% ahead not changing much from 4K the
700 XT is ahead of the 570 and average
1% and 0.1% lows holding a 12% lead and
average frame rate alone once again the
4070 TI basically ties the 5070 with the
ladder slightly ahead this time 1080p
reintroduces other class cards the 570
TI ran at 167 FPS average with the 570
at 138 that's still 21% there the 470
hasn't been rerun here yet but the 370
is present at 85 FPS yielding a 62% lead
to the 570 followed by the 270 at 60 FPS
for 130% then the GTX 1070 at 35 FPS
average that's about 293 improved to the
570 and the rx700 XT seems like it'll be
particularly relevant soon this one ran
at 150 FPS average with lows expected at
116 and 104 that's an 88.8% improvement
over the 5070 d light 2 is up now this
is another of the heavier games
especially with rt later at 4K the 570
ran at 56 FPS average and struggled in
this title allowing the 570 TI an
advantage of 25% the 7800 XT doesn't
look great by comparison here at 55 FPS
average itself as for the 4070 TI it's
again roughly equal 1440p has the 570 at
106 FPS average now Trading Places with
the 7800 XT the 570 TI's lead is reduced
to 22% with the 4070 TI now falling
slightly behind the 570 by generational
naming the 470 ran at 78 FPS average so
the 570 is 36% better the 370 was at 67
FPS average or 60% better on the 5070
today Resident Evil 4 is up last for
rter testing and we're almost through
these at 4K the 57078 FPS average has it
just behind the 4070 TI that we've been
tracking it's also about 6 FPS ahead of
the 7800 XT so measurably different but
functionally equal the 5070 TI is 107
FPS average positions at 36% ahead in
this one which is a huge gain and among
the largest we've seen the 7800 XT seems
like a good and definitely very relevant
soon comparison for AMD landed at 100
FPS average and leading the 570 by 28%
at 144p the 570 held a 152 FPS average
and trailed the 4070 TI by 8 FPS the 570
TI 30% higher frame rate here down from
36% at 4K as we've seen the Gap tends to
close at lower resolutions although it's
still a huge gap in this particular game
the 7800 XT is now up at 186 FPS average
with a reduction of the percentage
advantage to 22% from 28% at 4K
generationally the 570 runs 23% faster
than the 124 FPS on the 470 54% faster
than the 91 FPS on the 370 and 157%
ahead of the 59 FPS for the 270 finally
for raster we're now at 1080p for
Resident Evil 4 this one is interesting
for further closing of the gap between
the 5070 and 5070 TI which now ranges
from 282 fps to 224 FPS for a 26%
Improvement on the ti the 7800 XT is
about 18% higher frame rate here we're
moving on to raate tracing now Nvidia
has historically held significant
advantages in some games for raate
tracing AMD says it has significantly
improved its rate tracing performance
though we explained why the company is
claiming this and our news piece
covering the 9070 announcements so this
will become highly relevant in
tomorrow's reviews black myth who call
with Ray tracing is up first this is one
of the two titles in this RT test Suite
that heavily favors Nvidia we testing
with upscaling here at 4K the 5070 ran
at 40 FPS average that has the 5070 TI
at 30% ahead with the 470 TI About tied
with the 5070 AMD doesn't appear until
the 700 XTX down at 20 FPS average
that's a massive lead of 99% over the
700 XTX the 570 doubles the 700x tx's
performance that's not good for amd's
last generation well if that lead can be
HED with the new generation though the
5070 leads the 3080 by 44% based on math
from amd's claims in its presentation
that's about where it should land here
too bad no one knows if that's a good
reference point yet at 1440p the 570 TI
ran at 88 FPS average the 570 at 73 FPS
average between the 4070 TI and 470 TI
super and the original RTX 70 class card
the 2070 ran at 24 amd's best here as of
today and not tomorrow is the 700 XTX at
37 FPS average now for 1080p the 570
held a 97 FPS average here encroaching
on the 490 but still not beating it the
570 TI leads the 570 by just 15% in this
situation with the 570 now ahead of the
470 TI and TI Super Cards after slow
gains and other resolutions the 7800 XTX
ran at 49 FPS average closer to a 460
and behind the 3070 that's unfortunate
AMD named the 380 and it slideshow
announcing the card for the 907s if it
lands near that Mark it'd be around or
ahead of the 66 FPS average result for
the ftw3 speaking of evj really knew
what was coming when it bailed Dragon
Dogma 2 is back with rt now this one is
more balanced between the vendors at 4K
the 5070 ran at 49 FPS average
establishing a 9% lead for the 700 XT
it's a similar Gap to what we saw
without RT the 5070 TI leads by 30%
again here with the 700 XTX leading that
at 1440p with rt Dragon Dogma 2 puts the
570 at 83 FPS average reducing the 570
TI's lead to 20 4% the 700xt sits
between both with the 7800 XTX ahead of
the 570 TI based on the charts AMD has
released the math would position the 970
970 XT as flanking the 570 TI but we'll
find out soon enough generationally the
570 leads the 470 by 23% the 370s 51 FPS
by 62% and the 2070 non super by 145%
down to 1080p the 5070 TI's lead over
the 570 is now 22% with the 700 XTX
still leading the TI and the 7800 XT
still leading the 570 the 470 is
relatively close to the 570 here now
with an 18% advantage to the 570 but
maybe the 490 can breathe some
excitement into it the 490 ran at
169.254 by a billion that put it at
107.4 billion FPS average which is an
uplift of
6,347
51673 per. this is clearly the card to
get and as we all know it's not possible
to multiply the 490 by arbitrary numbers
with loss to scaling because then that
would hurt 50 Series marketing d light 2
with rt is next the first one is 4K
upscaled for this chart the 570 ran at
44 FPS average here just below the 4070
TI the 700 XTX held 46 FPS average in
this one again showing amd's prior
deficit in RT performance it's not as
bad as in black myth but considering the
original pricing of the 4070 TI the s00
XTX AMD was in a position that was hard
to fight from we'll see how the 970
series Compares tomorrow at 1440p the
5070 beats the 700 XT by 133% falls
behind the 4070 TI and allows the 570 TI
which is basically an RTX 480 V3 or V4 a
lead of 27% at 1080p upscale the 570
produced 116 FPS average and again sat
just below the 470 TI with the 7800 XTX
and 7800 XT flanking the 570 the 570 TI
ran at 141 FPS average which will be the
number for amd's 970 XT to Target
generationally the 570 leads the 47 by
25% and the 370 by 58% Resident Evil at
4K upscale ises next this one has the
570 at 91 FPS average roughly tie in the
470 TI once again the 700 XT leads the
570 by 18% with the 570 TI leading by
29% the 700 XCX sits ahead of that at
134 FPS average at 1440p the 570 is 149
FPS average put it 23% ahead of the 470
and 70% ahead of the 3070 the 700xt
leads the 470 TI and 570 finally for RTS
a lot of charts today finally for RT our
new Cyber Punk results with the updated
game version First with 4K and RT Ultra
the 5070 ran at 17 FPS average this is
without upscaling it's intentionally the
heaviest workload for gaming we run that
positions it right between the 700 XT
and 700 XTX that'd be unfortunate
positioning if AMD weren't launching
something with better RT in a day but
we'll have to check back tomorrow for
that rank the 570 TI continues its trend
of being nvidia's thirdd or fourth
duration of a 4080 card and leads the
5070 by huge 56% here the workload is
simply too heavy for the 5070 it is
dropping frames a lot uh frame time
pacing is bad it just can't handle it's
getting overrun it has neither the
bandwidth nor the compute capability
that's why you see that Gap emerge
here's RT Ultra at 1080p the 570 held 64
FPS average with these settings putting
the 570 TI About 32% ahead the 700 XTX
Trail is the 570 here unfortunately for
amd's former Flagship we also run RT
medium for cyberpunk we found that RT
Ultra and RT medium can significantly
affect the hierarchical ranking of
Nvidia and AMD so we run both Nvidia
runs away at Ultra they get closer
sometimes here with these settings and
at 4K still the 570 now runs at 22.5 FPS
average this reduces the 570 T lead to a
more normal 35% the 570 just didn't have
the ability to keep up at 4K RT Ultra
we'll keep thermal short and simple
using our usual Benchmark of Port Royal
at 4K and looping we measured the 570 Fe
at steady state at around 7 4° CI for GP
core temperature the memory temperature
was about 76° both of these numbers are
acceptable memory is well within spec
and it's completely fine here core has
some room for a hotter case as in
computer case the core temperature isn't
impressive but it is acceptable and
there's a little bit of buffer there the
570 fees fans ran at about 2500 rpm to
maintain this temperature we skipped
acoustic testing this time since we have
the two 970 reviews to get through so
for efficiency as usual we use power
interposer PMD 2s in between the GPU and
the power supply that means we're
intercepting slot power and the pcie
power through the cables and we do that
so that we can isolate the GPU entirely
measure its power consumption during a
workload and then we take the frame rate
numbers to do some simple math and
produce an efficiency number so in these
charts you'll get a few things you get
the total power consumption for that
workload in watts and then you also get
its efficiency in fps per watt not
workload normalized so we allow it to
run it the frame rate uh that it can
naturally run at for efficiency with
Final Fantasy 14 at 4K we ended up with
this data this chart isn't as dense as
our 1440p chart that's up next the 570
Fe ran at 0.33 FPS per watt here pulling
233 Watts during the workload the 570 TI
pulled 264 Watts allowing it an
improvement and efficiency to 0.37 FPS
per watt amd's prior 7800 XT wasn't
particularly efficient giving Nvidia a
large advantage and efficiency for the
570 the FPS was close enough to be
mostly observably equal to a player but
the 7800 XT ran at just 0.25 FPS per
watt from its 324 Watts power draw
during the test we'll have to see what
the 970 series does to improve this as
this has been one of amd's GPU
weaknesses over the years at 1440p the
5070 ran at 0.65 FPS per watt that puts
the 5070 TI as about 12% more efficient
than the 5070 when producing a variable
workload the AMD 7900 XT pulled 325
watts in this test landed at 0.53 FPS
per watt its frame rate is is higher but
the power is also disproportionately
higher which hurts its efficiency
despite a higher frame rate at 1080p the
570 hits nearly 1 FPS per watt the 4060
TI has passed it for efficiency with the
570 TI improved by 0.11 FPS per watt on
top of the 55070 is 1.0 result the 700
XT is down at 0.75 and is still pulling
about the same power as previously f124
at 4K and with r tracs up next in this
one the 5070 produced 0.17 FPS per watt
pulling close to TDP at 240 6 watts in
order to produce its hardly playable
frame rate the 570 TI ran at 0.20 FPS
per watt with the 480 ranking at the top
for its balance of power and frame rate
note that bar size changes you might see
from numbers that look the same are
valid it's just from the hidden decimal
places the 700 XT ran at 0.12 FPS per
watt a significant fall from the 507s
result the 970 Series has a lot of work
to do here uh to start to close the gap
with Nvidia which has a major advantage
right now in efficiency at 1080p and
still with rt the 5070 ran at 0.55 FPS
per watt again giving the 5070 TI a 13%
efficiency Advantage we're curious to
see where the 970 and 970 XT land the
7900 XT for its case isn't competitive
in efficiency with a lot of this
particular result being because of its
relatively low RT performance last
generation and that's what AMD is trying
to tackle and black myth who con without
RT and at 1080p the 570 TI held a 0.53
FPS per watt rank putting it in the
second slot the 70 is at 0.48 with the
4060 TI still trading back and forth
depending on the test the 7800 XT was at
0.31 FPS perad with a 7900 XT just below
that the 570 is not nvidia's most power
efficient card due to the performance
trade-offs but it's relatively efficient
overall in Dragons Dogma 2 at 1440p and
with rt the 570 ranked at 0.36 FPS per
watt sandwiching it between the 490 that
it's not better than and the 590 the 700
XD is down at 0.28 FPS per wat yielding
and efficiency benefit in a
non-normalized frame rate workload of
29% that'll be the mark for the 970
series to hit finally in Starfield rized
at 1440p the 570 ran at 0.43 FPS per
watt and landed just below the 490 which
it Remains Not better then again the
7800 XT from AMD ran at 0.32 FPS per
watt so AMD has a lot of ground to gain
here tomorrow this will be an area we'll
focus on for testing for improvements as
theoretically it should be better than
it was before we have some more numbers
in our upcoming 9070 VI as well so like
the 470 super for example reappears in
those charts if you're curious about
that one we're just holding some stuff
for the 970 and the 970 XT cuz those
will be pretty big reviews as well so if
you want to know where the 470 super is
check back for that but it's between the
470 and the 570 one thing for certain
though nvidia's marketing about the 570
versus the 490 is wrapped in [__]
and built on a foundation of manure
which is I guess only fitting for a
company whose CEO is constantly wearing
leather jackets do you like my jacket so
that's it for the benchmarks a lot of
benchmarks we added more efficiency than
we've had the last several reviews again
because we're prepping for AMD to
reenter the scene and uh we've gotten
the efficiency charts built up now so
anyway the current buying experience is
completely insane it matches that Co era
boom where things went crazy it also
kind of matches the 2017 or so crypto
mining boom uh both of which depleted
Supply we're seeing that again
definitely disheartening to see um but
anyway uh it's it's crazy it's crazy to
go to Newegg and sort by $450 to $650
which used to be like one of the most
popular category I mean far enough back
it was the flagship high-end but more
recent history it's been sort of that
modern mid-range really popular price
category especially if you start down at
400 450 and uh it's gone it's all it's
all gone it's the South Park meme it's
gone it's all
gone what's all gone the money in your
account it didn't do too well it's
G what do you mean I I have $100 not
anymore you don't poof there's there's
nothing left so 7800 XT PSE and a bunch
of refurb units and that was it so
really crazy makes it very difficult to
evaluate value and now fortunately we're
going to wait to do that anyway because
the 970 the 9070 XE launch tomorrow when
this video goes up and that's when we're
going to evaluate the value of the 5070
and its direct competitors broadly
speaking regardless where it lands we'd
say wait for things to cool off if your
current machine can last you a little
bit longer I mean most people can
probably wait at least a day you'll
likely save money as pricing settles if
saving money doesn't matter to you maybe
the time does Because unless you get
lucky and snipe an early stock of the
cards you may at least be saving some
time all right so that's pretty much it
as for the value we're going to kick
that can to tomorrow's review because we
we want that data before we really talk
about it I I don't know I need an anchor
point to talk about the value and right
now there's not really one so uh yeah
we're we're going to wait and uh we'll
talk about it then but either way we
don't think you should buy this card
until you learn about the competition as
the on paper price is in similar
territory and we'll see how the in
reality price is for both of them so
check back for the 970 XT and the 970
reviews this gets you the basics for now
we'll have a lot more to talk about
tomorrow thanks for watching subscribe
for more to support reviews like this
and our independent testing we spend a
lot of time on this these days you can
go to store. Gamers nexus.net and grab
one of our PC Building anti-static mod
mats that we've been selling for years
now with PC Building diagrams screw
tracking grids two scale memory and all
kinds of other stuff we've also got
soldering and project mats for high heat
resistance projects and we have our
copper plated stainless steel Mule mugs
alongside our coaster packs that are 3D
and PC themed you can grab one of those
on the store to help us out directly and
get something cool in return thanks for
watching subscribe for more we'll see
you all next time